ja und jetzt kommt ein exemplar erstmals
voraussichtlich der erde mit bis zu 6800
kilometer entfernung so nah wie noch nie
jedenfalls für nächsten plan dass wir
dabei beobachten können das ist besser
als zum beispiel die entfernung der
geostationären satelliten mit rund
36.000 kilometern fliegt also
wahrscheinlich darunter durch zum ersten
mal wird die nasa die flugbahn
mitverfolgen können und ihr
verteidigungssystem techniken welche
gefahr von diesem vorbeiflug ausgebe
back die natur kann jetzt wirklich vom
feinsten fiction herzlich willkommen 1
12 oktober ist es soweit mit 2012 these
4 nähert sich anna street so dicht wie
niemals zuvor zumindest einer der vorher
entdeckt wurde
denn auf der erde schlagen ständig sehr
große abzuheben ein nur dass das kaum
jemand bewusst ist bisher wurde nämlich
davon ausgegangen dass zum beispiel der
aktuell von chelyabinsk eine seltene
aufnahme und außerdem nicht so
gefährlich gewesen weiß lass' uns aber
ein trugschluss das rät der 2003 auf
grund eines einschlag winkels fast
komplett verglüht ist hätte mit einem
anderen winkel eine großstadt komplett
zerstört verglichen mit der hiroshima
bombe hatte er den 20 bis 40 fache
sprengkraft entsprechend tnt war als sie
vom wechsel an die atombombe über
hiroshima abgeworfen wurde hatte eine
sprengkraft von entsprechend 15
kilotonnen tnt ein noch größeres
exemplar 2013 sehr dicht an der erde
vorbeigeflogen 2012 der a14 flug
unterhalb der geostationären satelliten
durch allerdings änderte der asteroid
dabei seine flugbahn und auch vor dem 12
tc 4 könnte gefährlicher werden wenn
seine größe wird auf bis zu 50 meter
geschätzt er könnte also theoretisch
ein zehn mal größeres volumen haben
als der aktuelle von china bis die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er auch der
airline steckt wurde mit 1 zu 14.000
rechnet also keine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit aber immerhin
deutlich größer als beim lotto die
chance auf den hohen gewinn
die gefahr ist also groß von einem
solch riesigen himmelskörper getroffen
zu werden und 2012 c c4 ist nur einer
von millionen gesprochen die in unserem
sonnensystem herum fliegen und etwa eine
million aktiven davon befinden sich im
bereich der erdumlaufbahn davon kennen
wir 10.000
exakt 1 und zudem ist nur sehr schwer
einzuschätzen ob die asteroiden mit der
erde kollidieren
da sie ihre flugbahn oft ändern das
geschieht auch ganz ohne den vorbeiflug
an großen planeten zum beispiel durch
die einschläge von anderen kleinen ast
zu ihnen immer mehr wissenschaftler
waren jetzt vor dem hohen risiko eines
großen einschlags auf der erde die auch
das netz um 13 jahren passiert ist wurde
erst jüngst bekannt 26 18 ihren sind
auf der erde eingeschlagen darauf
gekommen sind findige wissenschaftler
sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten
atomteststopp überwachungs netzwerk
nachzufragen ob es andere größere
explosion auf der erde gab und zwar 26
und es konnten nur aktuellen einschläge
seien nichts anderes hat eine solche
buch lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei
vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem
himmel jedes jahr schlagen also zwei
größere akku ihnen hier auf der erde
ein
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn
die gesteinsbrocken schlugen im meer
wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein oder verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre
jetzt will die nasa bei 2012 steht für
die abwehr von asteroiden testen erster
stück die nachverfolgung des
afrika-cups 12 tc wir kennen wir ja
schon seit fünf jahren aber in dieser
zeit konnten wir ihn nur sieben tage
beobachten
deshalb weiß niemand ob er jetzt eher
270.000 kilometer von uns entfernt an
der erde vorbei zieht oder eben ganz
nicht mit 6800 kilometern in zukunft
will die nasa das aber exakt voraussagen
können deshalb soll der vorbeiflug
jetzt genutzt werden um die asteroiden
erkennung und nachverfolgung zu testen
denn das ist die voraussetzung um die
zukunft asteroiden aufzuspüren und dann
zu zerstören oder in flugbahn zu
ändern
hier klickst und asteroiden eins unserer
top themen wenn er kein video zum thema
und auch ja genau wenn ihr kein video
von oskar packen wollten hier ein abo
aufs auge
er ist nämlich ein sensationeller
blogger unvergesslich den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit aktuellen soll die erde jederzeit
mit noch mehr infos zu den gefahren die
von aktiven ausgehen das video
natürlich also nicht verpassen und auf
klicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten
bis dahin bleibt dran